hi guys I'm Greg hi I'm Brianna Brianna
white yeah that's how you say Brianna
have we had this conversation before
officially we have every video that I've
ever been on your channel I go and I'm
Brianna white and you go Brianna here I
do like I just I don't really care so I
never mentioned it
yet the promise I was wearing jacket
yeah the jacket like maybe she'll stiff
how do you feel better I feel a lot
better
good you know what was looking for your
approval thank you
that's stranding trailer whoa I got all
this energy oh that's like og my game I
like hideo kojima a lot you know his
Metal Gear Solid's my all-time favorite
video game franchise
I specifically finally got a ps3 so I
could play part 4 and then so anyway I
know Hideo Kojima's done with that this
is his new one
yes trending yes I've heard very good
things yeah I'm very excited cuz you
know sometimes there's a lot of hype
surrounding games the way you said that
sounded like there's gossip no no not
like rumors so juicy us now Kojima
cheating on his fam
Oh dark humor from Breanna that's what
she does what were the juicy things you
heard let's just watch each other she's
okay great
oh no oh no [ __ ] was he the last time I
was nervous
oh the help
oh [ __ ]
it's pretty cool as in us
oh geez
there's no songs here
what is that
that's stranding huh
Jesus
I am fully 100% like what the [ __ ] did I
just watch I loved it I loved every
second of it that is like total it you
know like hideo kojima style to me
yeah just like showroom visceral it's
like every image is so carefully crafted
it starts with a naked guy right what is
with him with my naked buzz I know yeah
yeah that's got one point you players
yeah someone what your play is like
writing just completely naked then a
baby with umbilical cord still attached
yeah
something nothing him yeah they were
connected yeah they started cry as a
gonna fix it the baby and it's like our
babies that little Kim babies be that
little say you're like concern for the
health of this baby besides aren't you
he clearly cared about it that's
probably why it died is it was you know
born a little too early I don't know if
that's what was implied I don't know if
it ever was born maybe that was an
artistic interpretation ah oh that is
true I don't know I was then like it's
just like his he inference right like
baby's handprints that was baby's
handprints and that's how all the other
hand prints came to be like what are all
those other hand prints on his body that
are adult sized makes me wonder you see
all those fish along a body of water and
clearly some other sea animals were
getting washed up I think tidal wave why
am I thinking that I don't know how does
that she's usually a symbolism for life
yeah thanks actually yeah and it's
called death stranding
interesting I need to I need to learn
more what I love too is like okay Norma
Rita said I was supposed to be in the
Silent Hill game but I got can't I love
that meet Annie Okajima was like perfect
I could use you for this one I'm pretty
excited for this because it does look
like kind of graphics that we've seen a
metal gear but life you should have
Norman Reedus
yeah no they look fantastic I do Kojima
is probably dying to work on a new kind
of franchise lately I'm sure that
stranding is like brand new and I'm
excited for that because this is like a
reason I would get a ps4 I want to play
the new game yeah the one that's not a
sequel or something like that I I do
worry with games like this we haven't
seen too much this is a very basic
trailer I worry that it gets a little
too artistic which is some things can
get lost in it so it seems like it's not
a game for everyone it's not a game its
mass appealing but it seems like a
really polarizing game like most
artistic ventures people will either
really love it really hate it I'm stoked
rate and I [ __ ] like I have a big
love like Metal Gear is a very important
like game to be like I feel the Bears
that I'm only like now getting to part
four but the only reason I recently got
one was because like I recently played
injustice and I've loved it and I was
like damn I want to get like more video
games and I got metal gear and knowing
Hideo Kojima's like doing this yes he
has a wild imagination and I can't wait
to see what the other side is different
kind of artists that you just walk you
always follow what he does no matter
what he does you know
transition now subscribe today please
thanks Brianna white please tell us
about your awesome channel that I love
watching every morning and evening she
uploads four times a day that why would
you put that pressure on me people are
always asking for more uploads I'm like
I'm already uploading every day what
more could you want more videos that
they have one video a day but it's um
well some of them are like an hour long
so anyways I do Let's Plays on my gaming
channel